15th season of such my compadre from the
NFL Network and NFL Media Group Andrew
Siciliano 15 years yeah now when you
first when you first did it cuz again
NFL Network is turning 17 this year of
16 this year so we were on the air for
one year you come on next and and Ward's
the host people at the time thing you
know what it's been on for 25 years but
what did would you hear generally from
people 15 years ago I don't know who's
watching and honestly the first year it
was so the first year David Hill who was
then at Fox and at DirecTV had this idea
they had the contract with the league to
do it but it was it was supposed to be
the following season okay
and David said I'm coming on and I'm
doing it with Fox this year so we're
putting on the Fox games now CBS said no
no no we sign up for next year right so
you can't show our games live so the
first year we could only show Fox games
live didn't get a lot of promotion it
wasn't in high-def most stuff wasn't
then but it had just started like Fox
was doing high def games CBS not yet
there were times where there might only
be three games at 1:00 Eastern that we
could show or the other the other way
around you could have like six games at
1:00 and maybe only one game at 4:00
right so I don't know that the product
was even that good at first but we
eventually got there we didn't we didn't
invent America's short intention spent
attention span right but we kind of came
around right around the time where no
one can focus on it for more than three
four five minutes at a time and then
there's nothing like when four or five
games are coming right down Jewellers
with two minutes and then you had the
late ones beginning as well you get that
15 well they've pushed the late window
back a little bit now right but that is
by far the best time do you win Scott
Hansen's meet anywhere sort of what
nunchuks like like the end of anchorman
you know we we have we have never done
that do you want to do that
no if I could mention another show Leba
tarde had us on I know that yeah and he
tried to get us the fight he's like no
no like Scott Hanson is a lover man he's
not yes they tried to get us the fight
did not happen we pass in the hallway
and NFL Network every now and then right
and there's the nod and the fist bump
cuz you know Scott's not a big handshake
touch the doorknob kind of guy so
there's the fist bump kind of thing and
it's all mutual respect we still have
every Sunday though he and I will both
get tweets and texts and some positive
some negative I can't believe you just
said that my 1b and vice versa I can't
believe you missed that touchdown like
wouldn't mean wasn't you or we get thee
because there are two and still to this
day all these years later people don't
realize there are two different shows
right two different products you get the
dude I can't believe you quit or how did
you take your sick yeah how do you take
the day off and we both walk I don't
think either of us respond anymore right
but it would be no no you just went to
your buddy's house and your buddy gets
the other one what do you mean there's
another one crazy they don't hit it oh
you know so now do you think there's
anyone today waking up and complaining
to their quarterback why'd you quit
thinking that that he was Andrew Luck
absolutely there was there what you
think of Andrew Luck Andrew um so the
initial reaction I think we all had was
like you gotta be kidding me this is a
fake shefter account right I was on the
air doing the Rams game here with um you
know Kimes and Nate Burleson where a spa
you're on there live right yeah we're on
live it's the first quarter at six
twenty six whatever it was landfill time
here ransom rock Rams Broncos nobody is
playing you're trying to come up with
storylines already even in the first
quarter right and our head of
broadcasting Jory Hirsch text me luck
retired two words and like you stare at
it a few times
look written time luck luck so then I
switched to Twitter and I see
immediately and then I had the same
reaction this has to be a fake shefter
account or he got hacked but then you
see had already been following it up
with another tweet
and I needed them to know my partners
next to me but they have open headsets
and I was legitimately concerned that if
I hold the phone up and they read it
yeah oh yeah right I know and so I did
this I put my finger over my lips right
right and I held it up to the two of
them and to see their eyes go across
back and forth to screen and then they
just went I know right the thing I
couldn't believe is I was you know doing
my best to pay attention to my wife and
children with whom I was having dinner
at nights to be present just yes yeah
you know and then the game day morning
crew starts texting each other and Kurt
can't believe it mooch can't believe it
and we're all just in disbelief I did
notice that luck was on the sidelines
during the game that was going on if I
didn't even realize they were like you
couldn't believe it and I'm like
suddenly wondering so wait a minute
the report was he's going to tell his
teammates today or after the game and
then have a press conference Sunday and
then he's having a press conference
within an hour all of a sudden because
it seems like all the plans changed and
it was just an unfortunate turn of
events that that's the way that luck
leaves the game yes
shock and surprise difficulty in shaping
the message gets booed by a large
proportion of the fans that he is
delighted through his seven years and
then as a press conference on the spot
that was really weird what a weird wild
Saturday night he was gonna be a
sympathetic figure I think to many not
all obviously but too many regardless
the idea though that and I'm not blaming
Adam Adam had the story Adam had to go
with the story how could he not but if
you see the beginning of that 24 minute
presser when he walks out there he kind
of mumbles something like I this is not
what I wanted right wanted or this is
not what I had experice unday morning
with that cup of coffee and sit down and
write something really thoughtful
because that's who he is right and I
think he had some of his notes maybe I
couldn't tell if he was reading off his
phone at least at the beginning but then
he just rift and it was it was one of
the most human open and raw moments I
think we have seen in a long time from
any athlete on a podium and if you truly
watched all of that and tried to see him
as a human which I know for some fans is
difficult not all fans but some then I
don't know how you can be mad at him
you'd be upset with the timing maybe I
get that but just listen and see the
look on his face you gotta walk away and
say dude good for you gave his body your
seven years yeah he left he look his
next contract would have been mass
massive massive because by the time he'd
signed it
mahomes would have signed I mean the
number of Million Dollar Man right he
could have could have 35 a year minimum
and then his next contract would have
been up when he was 36 37 he could have
kept going and going
made of ton of money but clearly his
body wasn't willing to go along with it
and then the diamond in between his
temples is something that I know this is
coming next April and next March the
concept of our ploy people who are too
smart good solid bets in the draft
already we've heard that stuff and do
you really love football that drives me
nuts it drives me nuts that it's gonna
be well that he's just 29 years old he's
just too much of a thinker he's got a
book club you know he's he's his words
like Luddite that's why no that's but
that's why he he has retired because he
thinks too much you need just somebody
who is just turns part of his brain off
enough to be able to play football and
and we're gonna hear it and that's gonna
really piss me off from this whole we
heard it when he came out of Stanford
how dare he go back to school
to focus on learning his senior year how
dare he actually want to finish his
degree his senior year he was I hate the
cliche outside the box but he did it
differently then like Matt Leinart went
back for his senior year and his dad I
think eventually kind of said matches
like college too much that was his
reason man drew loved college I mean he
didn't want to be on TV he wanted to be
the guy that that rode his bike to class
and dove into his books he wanted to be
the book club guy and that's kind of why
see I thought if he were to quit early
it would be hey I got a concussion I
don't want to do this anymore
the idea that he's leaving with a lower
leg injury I think that's what's hard
for a lot of fans well dude just give it
a couple more weeks I know you'll be
fine in a month and Peter Kingsley fine
Peter King's gonna join me top of the
next hour that's part of what he was his
reporting in his football morning in
America is the Colts attempted to spend
part of last week to say look let's just
put you on IR let's see how it goes
Andrew Siciliano here in the Rich Eisen
show from red zone here on DirecTV and
NFL Network and you know the issue is is
that he just didn't feel he could make
it through another situation of dealing
with pain and Rehab and then not knowing
and he's already drained and miserable
and why not live life I bet you and you
said Sunday morning he wanted to wake up
have a cup of coffee write something out
or fine-tune what he has written out to
prepare and retire and the fact they
didn't get to do it Saturday night
because he couldn't he couldn't do it on
Sunday because he had to do it on
Saturday night maybe really disappointed
him but I bet you he woke up Sunday
morning with the weight of the world off
his shoulders absolutely but though and
I'm trying to give this to so many fans
who are disappointed that maybe their
Super Bowl season is gone because that
is what is generally important to the
fan certainly one that has put thousands
of dollars into a public seat license
etc and so forth
I understand that but he probably woke
up Sunday morning weight of the world
off his shoulders hoping that the worst
part of this is over now go live your
life with with your your new wife he'll
travel the world and see what's next
exactly live the life that that that
Stanford degree affords you that that
diamond as you said between your ears
affords you if you go back to things Zac
Kiefer the writer in Indianapolis had
that tweet that probably got like 40
thousand retweets on Saturday night with
the list of all his injuries yes I start
allege the internal injuries the the
shoulder all the operations take that
into account and then hosting
up-to-the-minute now NFL now at NFL
Network we're changing names again
the last couple of years and really in
fronting and watching every single one
of his pressors as he went through all
this process there were a couple of
moments where I don't say it got dark
but you could see over the last year and
a half where when he really really
opened up about the process of coming
back of missing that entire season about
like going through these treatments in
Europe about which he was very evasive
right about living in Europe with his
then girlfriend now wife and getting
away from it all and the privacy he had
there and how much he doubted himself
and that little comment about Jacoby
Brissette during Saturday's presser
where he said I came back and I resented
this guy you could see it now he loves
him he's a friend for life he said but
you could see these little signs of how
much this entire thing was eating him
from the inside and to your point I
guarantee you you're right when you will
when he woke up Sunday all of that was
gone well to put a button on it I hope
that fans and we can all look at Lux
retirement not through the prism of many
people saying how weak it is or how
disappointed his hollerman weak it is
disappointing it is selfish it might be
and look at it to say remarkable how
many quarterbacks probably go through
the same damn thing and play at this
level
and for as long as they have and I think
maybe we should just use this as a prism
to just see how much body blood sweat
and tears does get put on the line every
single Thursday Monday or Sunday on the
red zone through your television sets
and the car crashes that happen as Howie
long is described a pro Football Hall of
Famers described every single play being
a car crash well perhaps that's the way
we can all look at it before I let you
go you mentioned how you are the
play-by-play voice of pre-season Rams
football and I will turn to you the
latest Rams insider if you will can
somebody can you tell me what the hell
happened with Todd Gurley zni last year
sure and what it bodes for 2019 ng
Sicilian absolutely I can tell you what
I know and I don't think people are
lying to me there is no super-secret
story here there they're not hiding
anything from the world in any way shape
or form Todd Gurley the last three years
has been on the field not not taking the
ball but been on the field for 70% of
the Rams snaps 70 more yards from
scrimmage touchdowns touches than any
other back in the National Football
League last year he did get banged up
they sat him down two games in December
remember he came back against the
Cowboys and had a hundred yards in that
playoff game and he was fine but he had
the wear and tear of any workhorse
running back down the stretch when you
take into account there's a knee injury
coming out of college they need to
lessen the load they NBA load management
I understand that they need that week's
13 through 17 where I understand they
kept him out right and then riding a
bicycle during workings of the NFC
champion Shawn McVeigh would admit that
he probably and I don't want the words
in his mouth probably had a little bit
of a quick hook in New Orleans now Todd
Gurley miss played two balls I believe
he had a drop pass on third down and
maybe a fumble but either way the first
two drives the first quarter in New
Orleans brecht not his finest quarter
McVeigh probably had a bit of a quick
hook then they won that
they did Jared Goff lights out in that
game his best performance forget about
the Chiefs game the Vikings game that
game was his masterpiece nothing went
well on the Superbowl now I sound like
an excuse maker here I realize if you
take away the holding call on John
Sullivan in the fourth quarter that
wiped out a 20-yard todd gurley gain
which sets them up on that final drive
to potentially yes finally get in the
end zone
his numbers look a lot different but I'm
with you nothing went well that night
against Bill Belichick at the Super Bowl
so what about 2019 I think he is going
to be fine I think he's going to be
dynamic
if you're asking from a fantasy
perspective no I will I'd say they will
they want to lessen the load and that is
why they went and got Darryl Henderson
that he'll be the album camara to the to
the marking her mother and they need a
guy to lessen the load okay and come in
on third down or get ten carries Todd
Gurley is gonna have a thousand yards
he's gonna have double-digit touchdowns
he's gonna be a WoW player I don't know
that he's gonna be 1,800 yards and 17
touchdowns because they don't want to
give him that kind of workload Andrew
Sicilian on both Twitter and Instagram
and of course catch him for season 15 of
him being the host of the red zone Janet
elevate and so and yes indeed get a free
preview free preview of DirecTV Sunday
Ticket Max on September the 8th all your
out-of-market games DirecTV red zone
with this man and DirecTV fantasy zone
no cost for week 1 of the NFL season go
to DIRECTV calm to subscribe great to
see you brother thanks wrap Peter King
and Ryan Leaf on all these subjects and
more but when we come back your phone
calls and yes a little bit of what I
experienced that Chavez Ravine this
weekend everybody everybody Chavez
Ravine it was a billion degrees in the
Yankees wore all black uniforms and I'm
gonna go for Costanza on you and we come
back on the Rich Eisen show for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 under red TV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app